honnêtement moi j'ai fait l'erreur quand
j'ai commencé la télé j'avais pas de
honte à gagner de l'argent tu en as fait
qu'une on est sincèrement j'ai fait
l'erreur j'ai dit j'étais content
j'avais jamais vu dit voilà je suis
content je suis fier une ferrari veine
ashton ça m'a été reproché mille fois la
différence je trouve qu'on gagne de
l'argent ce n'est pas très grave de le
dire et de montrer ce que je ne supporte
pas c'est qu'on passe de la molle de
confesser à marolles aux autres - cas
footeux bon moment une rolex à 450000
euros
c'est son problème il gagne très bien sa
vie quel est le problème alain temps non
qu'elle est nommée cessenon quel est le
problème je comprends que ça choque la
somme évidemment coc hors de prix
montent à ce prix là mais en même temps
il mbouda rang qui tue qui fasse mais de
quoi moi je préfère un mec il met sa
montre et qui a su king pognon que celui
qui dit non j'ai une quel tome et qui
ment en 2004 soit ça m'horripile ça il
faut être honnête thuillet du pognon tue
le montre new tunes mon jeu télé monte à
450 me et pas faire un poste avec la
photo mathieu de leurs meilleurs pardon
tu confonds de choses tu confonds aimé
avoir aimé montrer mais montrer voilà
ces gens là je crois que c'est même pas
le fait d'avoir une monde qui lui fait
plaisir c'est le fait qu'on le voit et
pour lui c'est un signe de réussite et
les gens qui regardent
on associe la réussite à l'argent et
c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on aime c'est la réussite à de
mauvaises valeurs parce qu'en général je
me comprend les angoisses et les petits
canards et avec moi même et a réussi
mais les voitures sans vie de t'amuser
avec amuse toi
en revanche ces gens là le monsieur le
but c'est même pas de la conduire c'est
de montrer qu'ils n'ont eu et il est là
le problème